what I'm gonna do is show you one last
combination of symmetries I'm not gonna
take Scanlan point I'm gonna take point
and line and there's a little exercise
that goes with that and then I want you
to see if you can come up with your own
kind of symmetry right what can you
invent right okay so we've got this one
scale plus a point what happens when you
do scale last line well I'm gonna
construct it in a particular way okay
so right now I want you to leave off on
your square on your rosy looking thing
okay finish that off another time
underneath it though I want you to avoid
angle triangle but not just any right
angle triangle it's going to have these
exact proportions one two saw what this
other side to be twice as long okay now
that makes the hypotenuse how long
pythagoras square root of root pi right
if you if you put the two up here this
told me the square root of three but as
it is the hypotenuse is this fun so it's
a a 1/2 square root 5 triangle okay now
when you when you've drawn that okay you
probably will draw it in this
orientation now make it nice and easy
okay but once you do draw a nicety so
sighs I want you to rotate your page so
that the hypotenuse is like flat along
the bottom okay you don't have to but
it'll be easier for you now since I
can't rotate my whiteboard I'm just
gonna redraw this okay same triangle but
in a different orientation so you rotate
your page but I'm gonna have something
like this
one two square root of five okay so you
draw it oh man then you can read you
have the luxury of being able to rotate
your book but unfortunately I cannot say
here's my same one I've just turned it
around okay now we're gonna divide this
up in an unusual way that takes
advantage of scale in Lion surgery okay
I wonder if you should see where this
comes in okay the first thing you're
gonna do is see this point up here than
one with the right angle in it okay
we're going to drop down and altitude
remember what an altitude is it's going
to be it's how high it is so it's
perpendicular to the base and that's
what's pulling this the base is very
helpful okay so I've got this line
coming down
okay all right so there's my first
division I'm gonna do a few more okay
got to make sure I do it right take this
side of link to that we're called - okay
and let's bisect it so I'm gonna have
this here okay that's about halfway then
I want you to also bisect this side here
see how I've divided this up so you have
a hypotenuse I've got left play the
hypotenuse and the right part okay this
left Piper long apart I want you to
bisect this as well something like that
okay so this distance and this distance
will be the same okay so far so good now
you did two by sections okay I want you
to join up those two midpoints like sir
now you might be able to see it on mine
you should be able to see even better on
yours what to notice about this line you
just draw now that's parallel the
altitude and this line whatever it is
right no no all right now those two
parallel lines I want you to join up
with a perpendicular line like this it
goes across like that so from the side
of length two over to the hypotenuse
from side - over to the hypotenuse and
then our lasts joined okay is I'm gonna
go from this side to again
to the base or the foot of the now what
have we just made okay have a look at
this you can clearly see that seed is a
lot of reflectional symmetry in here
right can you see the can you see the
line symmetry for instance I can see
some line symmetry right I can see some
line symmetry yes there are other kinds
of symmetry that you can see right but I
don't my looks a bit square ehi but
yours should be quite rectangular okay
right now he's the challenge I want to
set to you okay Yuri started with the
one and the two and a spirit of foam
okay
but now we've introduced all of these
other subdivided sides okay now my
question to you is you've all
constructed it in the same way
so all that triangles should be the same
what are the links that have resulted
what's that like how about this one what
about this one now I want you to have a
go okay you know enough geometry to work
out all of these links taking the
original values and knowing carefully
how we constructed this triangle okay so
what I'm gonna ask you to do is try to
work out what these links out I just
picked up these terms you can pick some
other ones right what are those legs and
once you've found them what's
interesting about them okay so give that
a good I love this because we're
transition from your like in your normal
class you're like okay I'll work out
this length because the question says
find X or something like that but he's
just a puzzling scenario right and you
just like I want to know stuff just
because it seems a weird and interesting
right other things like a lot put some
labels on here not because the question
says they're labels but I struggle to
describe this adequately without being
able to say this is a this is B and this
is C people have been struggling to say
all right you know this corner and you
turned around and that language right
you don't have real labels it's very
difficult last year to call this
hey right now some of you most of you
have noticed similar triangles are going
to be very important okay now you can do
it in a few different ways let me show
you one way okay have a look at I'm
gonna put ABC the beat triangle I'm
gonna put it up on its side they said
there's the right angle the right angle
I've matched up to K I'm claiming this B
and this is C so BC is my own kind of
potenuse okay so we got a square root
five one two no problems okay now I'm
interested in some of these legs for
instance what is this altitude that was
one of the first questions I got ups so
I'm gonna compare that to this smaller
triangle
it's APB on mine okay now there's
similar how can you tell this similar I
know they look like it but how can you
tell yeah good yes I had a common angle
which which one yes well the 90 degree
is not common they're equal that's good
but I need one other angle I think it's
gonna be this one right that's all right
that angle is in the small triangle and
it's in the big triangle and you can
even see them here right so therefore
I'm going to say this right ABC is
similar to P be a if you match up the
vertices right and the reason is FP and
you look good okay I just showed you
those two angles right now therefore I
can say things about the ratios on the
sides okay I can say things about the
ratios of the sides for instance present
have a look have a look what kinds of
interesting things can you see here
this is one over here right so I can put
one here so that means with all of these
legs right or instance this side VP over
this sign a B right this side to this
side
smaller big sheep the same as a smaller
big right don't back up let's finish
this right well a B is just one so BP's
just lets me PM 1 and this is 105 isn't
it
105 one on Route five you can play the
game again and you get two on Route five
here right now if you keep on going all
the way throughout this triangle what
you'll notice is that well this triangle
is similar to the big one sorry well
guess what every other triangle is also
similar right so we've just divided up
this triangle into five triangles that
are Congo to each other and similar to
the big one okay you ready for your
brain to milk you can keep doing this
you can make them bigger but there's one
that way there's one this way there's
one over here and then there will be one
more here this big black triangle I've
created five triangles than that size
that's similar but the original one
right but it's it's what is this
it's scale symmetry okay it's also line
symmetry consuming things are reflected